you
we're excited about the publication of a
research project we've been working on
for a few years that I guess in a
nutshell we could call the oldest
archaeological site here in North
America for the last several decades
it's been considered fairly settled that
the earliest humans to set foot in the
Americas arrived no earlier than about
15,000 years ago now a recent paper
published in the scientific journal
Nature is calling that fact into
question the discovery of a far older
Mastodon skeleton holds clues that
seemed to suggest that ancient humans
arrived in North America over 100
thousand years earlier than previously
thought in 1992 while road crews were
excavating to build a sound berm along
Route 54 in near San Diego they stumbled
across an assortment of ancient fossils
when paleontologists arrived at the site
they discovered the remains of a variety
of extinct animals including the
direwolf Mastodon and ground sloth
according to uranium dating the site
dates all the way back to about 130,000
years ago while an exciting
archaeological site in its own right
what really made this discovery
intriguing was the fact that primitive
stone tools were also found among the
remains and that a mastodon skeleton
bares markings and fractures that
indicate it was deliberately broken
apart one tough even appears to have
been stuck up right into the ground
something that would be difficult or
impossible for a mastodon to achieve on
its own so what does that mean initial
findings at the site indicate that some
ancestor of modern humans possibly Homo
erectus or the Denisovans had arrived
and lived in the Americas for at least a
short while over 100 thousand years
earlier than previously thought
John McNab and expert on stone tools of
the University of Southampton said his
first reaction to the news was no this
is wrong something's wrong I didn't
believe it the site was determined to be
an ancient lake bed a likely site for a
small tribal home those many years ago
this is a monumental discovery because
currently the oldest widely accepted
site containing evidence of early
American States back to just 13,000
years ago with such a drastic shift in
the proposed understanding of early
human history many experts have
challenged the claim one proposed
explanation is that ancient humans
scavenged the remains of the mastodon
some thousands of years later as opposed
to dismantling the skeleton 130,000
years ago this assumption would require
the ancient people to have exhumed the
skeleton for reason
unknown which has never been observed
before this excavation would have left
telltale signs in the sediment layer in
which the site was discovered but no
such signs were present
additionally the mastodon bones appear
to have broken and fractured in a way
that suggests it was done while the
bones were still fresh researchers made
their own stone tools and smashed
elephant bones to judge the similarity
of the breaks in the Mastodon skeleton
and determined that it is indeed
plausible that some ancestral humans
dismantled the skeleton the proposed
130,000 years ago another challenge
posed by skeptics is the decided lack of
similarly ancient sites between the age
of the san diego highway location and
the current sites of roughly 13,000
years old this is a valid concern but
only if we assume that there is a direct
line of descent from the older humans to
the more recent ones the most likely
explanation is that the humans at the
older site were an isolated group that
likely died out long before the main
passage to the Americas that would mean
that there would be very few if any
other similarly dated sites another
possibility is that since this discovery
is the first of its kind researchers
haven't been looking in the right rock
layers to find similar specimens perhaps
now that one such example has been
uncovered paleontologists will turn
their attention to older layers and find
more remains one final point of
contention is the fact that there were
no human remains discovered at the San
Diego site this is not a particularly
troubling lack because the mastodon
remains very clearly show the evidence
of purposeful dismantling by stone tools
in any case the lack of human skeletons
can be explained any number of ways the
most likely being that the ones
responsible for the Mastodon skeleton
simply moved on to another location
before they died there very well could
be ancient human remains somewhere in
the region but of course only a very
small percentage of dead things end up
as fossils and if the site was home to a
small isolated batch of forerunners then
there's little hope for finding anything
despite rigorous attempts to disprove
the age of the discovery so far it seems
to be the real deal
Tom dem array of the San Diego Natural
History Museum says these patterns taken
together have led us to the conclusion
that humans were processing mastodon
limb bones and that this was occurring
at the site of burial 130,000 years ago
Jon McNab is right in assuming that most
experts would like the site to be more
thoroughly and rigorously studied but
the fact remains that if the California
site does turn out to be accurately
dated it would upend our current
understanding
human history and open up entirely new
avenues of research McNabb goes on to
say how implausible is 130,000 well
maybe it's not completely impossible but
it's less of a filling in of a gap than
an opening of a whole new chapter if
you'd like to learn more about this
exciting discovery check out the links
in the description make sure to
subscribe if you haven't already follow
second thought on your favorite social
media and leave a comment down below
with how you think this could change our
understanding of human history you can
watch my previous current events video
by clicking here or watch all my videos
by clicking here thanks for watching and
I'll see you in the next video
[Music]